[Music]  in the 70s they were an elite unit with  names like brick  champ  brian and ron  they rose like the phoenix and then  they were gone their legend became but a  whisper  told by the trees  until now  we're starting a 24-hour news channel  and we want you i'm going to do the  thing that god put ron burgundy on this  earth to do  have salon quality hair and read the  news  stop this just feels right the news team  is back  welcome to the 80s baby is that your  foot between my legs  use my hand  your hair looks like wet popcorn i like  the parts of your face that are covered  jack lyme look at him he's a prince he's  not that great what'd you say he said  you're not that great  [Music]  or uh jerry curl daily what are you  doing i'm breaking down the barriers of  race by assimilation and on that note  which one of you convicts with the  longest record can pass me the mashed  potatoes  [Music]  am i right  don't stop  believing  hold on  [Music]